Speaker 1: We have sadly tragic news from
Ukraine, where an American journalist has
been killed by Russian forces and another
journalist has been shot.
There were there were some incorrect things
reported about this story, and we're going
to correct those.
The Jerusalem Post reporting American journalists
killed another wounded by Russian forces near
Kiev.
The slain journalist was identified by Ukrainian
police as a 51 year old U.S. citizen and media
correspondent.
An American journalist was killed and another
wounded by Russian forces in Heirpod, near
the Ukrainian capital of Kiev.
The killed journalist was identified by Ukrainian
police as Bret Renard, a 51 year old journalist,
filmmaker and U.S. citizen.
While the Ukrainian authorities initially
identified Renard as the New York Times correspondent,
he was not in Ukraine on behalf of the Times.
So that's an important detail in the New York
Times also putting this out.
This doesn't make it any less tragic, but
initially it was reported as a journalist
working for the New York Times in Ukraine
was shot and killed.
It happens not to be true.
The New York Times putting out a statement
saying We are deeply saddened to hear of Bret
Raynaud's death.
Brant was a talented filmmaker who had contributed
to the New York Times over the years.
Though he had contributed to the Times in
the past, most recently 2015, he was not on
assignment for any desk at the Times in Ukraine.
Early reports that he worked for time circulated
because he was wearing a time's press badge
that he had been issued for an assignment
many years ago.
That's actually really common.
I know many, many journalists and reporters
who will just use an old press pass.
I've done it as well.
A decade ago.
Sometimes it's just hard to get a new press
pass and you just use an old one.
And that's it.
You're just identified as press and that that's
basically it.
So extremely, extremely tragic story, and
it is getting very, very serious there, including
not only do we now have journalists who have
been killed, but there is also video which
we're not going to play because it's still
very it's still very unclear exactly what
is allowed in terms of footage on YouTube
as well as on Instagram and Facebook, and
a lot of the platforms were on.
But there is now footage of from Mariupol
of what appears to be and it has not been.
It has not been contested at this point.
Russian tanks just firing upon a civilian
apartment building.
Now will the Russians later say, Well, we
believed it to be a base of operations for,
I don't know.
They've not said it yet.
And the video has not been contested.
So this is all getting very ugly.
And in the midst of this, we have conflicting
reports.
On the one hand, there are reports that progress
has been made on a potential serious cease
fire and peace talks between Ukraine and Russia.
That's good news if it's true.
At the same time, there are reports being
widely publicized that Vladimir Putin is now
looking to escalate the war.
Seeking military equipment from China could
both be true.
Sure, it continues to move very quickly.
And by the by Wednesday or Thursday, we should
have a sense as to whether the reports of
the cease fire talks getting closer is accurate
because typically those don't take more than
a few days from what a number of different
experts are saying.
We will follow it.
Let me know on Twitter at David Pakman what
you expect for the week ahead.
The David Pakman Show continues to be a community
supported program, you're in the community
when I say the community, I'm talking about
podcast listeners, YouTube viewers, people
watching on free speech TV or listening on
any of our radio affiliates, watching on our
television affiliates, any of you.
And we depend on your support through our
membership program, which you can find it.
Join Pacman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members,
and you can sign up in under a minute with
average computer skills at join Pacman dot
com.